welcome back to uno dei giochi più che
non vorrei far vedere la mia vecchia
prof
perché mi stimava un sacco non vorrei
che cambiasse la situazione siamo su
hughes adventure due perché hanno fatto
due visto che era così bello uno che ha
vinto la settimana scorsa l'ex fucking o
tra l'altro ragazzi non capisco se
effettivamente devo fare cose che sono
realmente successi perché questa è una
banana che sono realmente successo in
america eccolo lì cosa diavolo me ne
frega del sole ragazzi la scienza e poi
dicono che trofei spesso non è
istruttivo ma basta da un'altra app
state of trolli ti dovresti prendere il
coso è meta di un gelato le orecchie di
topolino per quale motivo questa cosa
ragazzi non l'ho capita ma non ho
neanche capito che cosa ma basta non ho
capito neanche cosa devo fare forse devo
schiacciare qua sul cappello o più sulla
sua fascia a eccolo a posto
tanto non capisco un cazzo la mia vita
ne vanno o con barack dove diavolo
nell'armadio degli illuminati con un
mago illuminato che fa il cosplay di ten
singh tutto a posto ragazzi sarà questa
la macchina del fumo no habla habla
altro no era meglio prima
niente non c'entrava magari devo fare
qualcosa quelle pro browser un aiuto
ragazzi uno solo
devo schiacciare più volte sul mago ok
cos'è cascato non ai ragazzi non negli
ultimi due livelli io questo non ho
capito cosa è successo
ma andiamo avanti la barbie questa è una
barbie storia americana perché perché la
barbie americana bella ci sta
barber strise vado sulla palla sulla
presa della corrente c'è un
c'è un così un sackboy dividervi
planetlab non picchiare che n mentre
kakà con l'iphone
barbie non lo fare non lo fare ken dai
file na de cata delle tue tanto qua si
parla sempre di merda perché sforzati
dai sforzati sforzati porco demonio non
sta capendo il problema in questa coppia
esci dal bagno se sto pagando basta
certo può essere unito quanto vede una
persona ma la cacca nello stesso posto e
non la faccio la mia ragazza esce essi
esci dal bagno santo iddio che scappa e
spreca gati addosso in questo momento
potrebbe essere esatto per far prediche
degli horror
a posto tutto ciò non ha senso sono
rimasto con due aiuti vabbè basta donald
trump basta mettere troppe nei livelli
metti qualcos'altro santo iddio metti a
questo tra l'altro è cast away
il film o no no perché tom hanks non
giocava con la sabbia prova verso no
bravissimo la trump tower sembrava mai
grasso complimenti quindi frolla
crollato trovato né col santo iddio non
ho capito nulla ma fa niente tanto si
capisce mai se trolley tofi nand e all
questo non l'ho capita e alla borsa
sasso saggio marchigiano dei più da new
york
perfetto il mio canale con iscritti e
invece il mio canale scende di iscritti
non volevo mahbub è una merda per
domarli tutti e quindi ho fallito
no era giusto così io non capisco questo
gioco ragazzi non lo capisco
andiamo avanti c'è un pelato che fa non
so chi sia walk of shame la volkoff m il
contrario
quindi mettono chi fa figure di merda
proprio per chi sia questo ma rimane
incollata ecco perché figure di merlo
che ha posto prova a tenere le mani
ancora di più no c'è un cane il cane
deve fare qualcosa che aveva a far
qualcosa sicuro esatto si tratta sempre
di merda e ragazzi
l'obiettivo di tuo gioco e far cagà no
no però dai spesso avviene duro non
c'eravamo ancora spinti oltre quindi
inutile che io mi lamenti
andiamo avanti ragazzi ho messo un
attimo a capire a capire questo guerra
di kfc bah io non avevo letto questo ok
qui c'è kfc contro mcdonald's c'è un
tizio in mezzo ma già tutti no mangia tu
no mangia tu no mangia tu bevi questo
magna questo è mai
e ridono funzionale sarà la gara era
giusto pure quindi fantastico troll cena
fai entrare the rock dalla john cena uk
inseminati lacca lo è sempre stato il
mio sogno da bambino vedere jones in e
schierarlo problema che il mio braccio
era grosso quanto il suo capo eccolo qua
e ti pareva muro per il messico va bene
lo sto costruendo ma lì mi dispiace sono
figli mattoni e non essere riuscito nel
suo piano diabolico fatto triste devo
farlo dato non l'ha costruito lui ho
tirato fuori uno schema adesso si sono
messi da soli
va bene andiamo avanti tutto ciò addio e
ninja ma come quando sto vedendo rock è
bellissimo c'è ninja che ha fatto la sua
comparsa il trofeo va bene niente di
strano andiamo avanti polizia shabelle
buona la ciambella un ragazzino non ho
capito no no allora ho finalmente adesso
troller rider acquista e angeli oliver
fatso contratto fino al contratto e
quindi che cosa ha firmato ma sai che
non ho capi case libri auto viaggi fogli
di giornale 26 no la casa e l'auto i
soldi tutto gratis per chi per questo
tizio quindi la al colera tommy vercetti
di
viva i siti credo dalla stessa camicia e
adesso è di act for food vabbè dai ma
che tristezza
adesso livello king john e tutti questa
non è una cena pacifica ma fa niente
non vedo il presidente conte andiamo
avanti
li ho invitati qua perché sono mister
bean no ho fatto cadere però degli
hamburger la mcdonald mangiatene tutti
allora la tara va bene però vedreste
disco a fare l'ultimo livello senza
usare lindt later usato l'ultimo inter
agazzino toccare lei
ok devo far uscire qualcosa da montali
mi ci gioco il canale proprio cosa fai
cosa che è successo ok la montagna forza
eccolo lo sapevo che era quello però io
pensavo ci sta di qua
[Musica]
è comunque della come l'originale è
complimenti bravi siete stati bravissimi
parola papa va e questo era l'ultimo
ragazzi questo era il vice pres
gli usa adventure sono diventato molto
più skillato litro al fisco i ragazzi
sono stato bravissimo
me lo dico da solo signori spero che
video vi sia piaciuto con la sezione più
giungere e vi piace iscritti al canale
perché ci saranno anche altri tratti di
questi non avete visto eroi come sempre
ci rivediamo a un prossimo video belle
ragazze
[Musica]